plus de deux ans de chantier près de 4,9
millions d'euros plus tard c'est
officiel la nouvelle halle du marché des
clayes-sous-bois est enfin terminé son
ouverture est prévue le 7 janvier
prochain
nous avons préféré laisser le choix aux
commerçants entre soi la fin de l'année
soit le début de l'année prochaine ils
ont préféré le début de l'année
prochaine pour assurer toutes là toute
la fin d'année dans l'ancien dans
l'ancienne halle du marché craignant ces
commerçants qui est peut-être quelques
fois quelques difficultés de démarrage
il faut dire que le chantier de ce
nouvel équipement a subi quelques
déconvenues
les travaux ont démarré fin 2018 et ont
ensuite été de nombreuses fois ralenti à
cause de la crise sanitaire ou encore de
problèmes de maîtrise d'oeuvre
certaines portes coupe feu n'était pas
aux normes donc il a fallu retarder d'un
mois
et puis tout au long du chantier il ya
eu un certain nombre de retards
mais bon tout est bien qui se termine
bien le marché flambant neuf sera donc
investi début janvier par la quarantaine
de commerçants déjà installés dans les
anciennes halles
ces dernières vont d'ailleurs connaître
elle aussi une nouvelle vie l'ancien
marchand et va être détruit et il y aura
un petit immeuble de entre 30 et 35
logements qui sera construit avec devant
cet immeuble
une placette de vie où il y aura
également le dimanche des marchés volant
qui pourront s'y installer et on
souhaite en rez-de-chaussée installer un
commerce
ou plusieurs commerces de proximité dans
l'idéal la municipalité aimerait
installer un bar ou un café un moyen
d'animer le marché du jeudi et du
dimanche matin